et bien bonjour bienvenue dans diagonale
le son avec le grand maître
international j'ai envie que chabanon
nous rejoindre bonjour stéphane alors
aujourd'hui qui nous a pris par les deux
sont tout à fait intéressante sur une
défense qui a été jouée par être dans
les joueurs danois
oui par les joueurs danois je pense que
c'est une défense qui a joué par à peu
près tout le monde et en même temps
c'est aussi une défense assez
intéressante pour faire ses premiers pas
face au coût 1 e 4 donc je pensais que
c'était important d'en parler c'est donc
la défense scandinave la fin scandinaves
on va voir donc eu deux sont aujourd'hui
sur cette ouverture la défense candidats
ont tout de suite passé à notre
échiquier
et alors jean-luc il ya des phases coni
n'avait est caractérisée après le
premier coup quand tu disais de 4 le
contre ici eu 2 e 4,2 début du curoir un
peu celle du tournoi et bien par un coup
très violent peut-être le plus violent
d'ailleurs qu'on puisse un des plus
violents qu'on puisse imaginer
au début ce qui contre attaque tout de
suite au centre en attaque ambiant
centrale avec le côté sain voilà ce qu
ici son fameux coup de dessins qui
contre attaque directement au centre
avec la dame qui protège et qui a l'air
d'être en cours tout à fait sain puisque
il attaque au centre est mais par contre
il va avoir un petit ennui ce coup là un
petit ennui
oui enfin disons que c'est un coup
direct c'est un coût qui donc qui
propose des changes elle peut enfin de
prendre le pur 4 directement donc le
seul inconvénient de ce coup c'est
finalement la vente principal
c'est-à-dire la prise du pion qui pose
une question importante au noir
c'est-à-dire faut-il sortir la dame ou
pas donc aussi vite dans la partie
voilà donc le problème effectivement si
les noirs après
les changes peut se faire dire si c'est
ce qu'on va voir tout de suite dès le 6
le meilleur coup les autres coûts sont
vraiment secondaires et pas vraiment
intéressant il faut prendre le pion et
dans ce cas là évidemment s'il est noir
reprennent de la dame tout de suite
eh bien on va voir que cette dame ici si
elle aura bien un centre tout de suite
elle est exposée c'est pour ça qu'on des
conseils de sortir et donc les pièces et
par exemple il ya d'autres composés mais
vous pourrez tout de suite attaqué la
dame avec le cavalier ici est donc posée
tout de suite la question là donc on
développe une pièce tout en attaquant la
dame ennemis qui du tout de suite un
souci et se pose la question doit
laisser la seule problématique pour
lancer des problématiques mais la
scandinave c'est la seule ouverture
sur les échecs je dirais en général ou
la dame peut sortir assez tôt sans qu'il
y ait une prise de risque énorme et en
même temps ça permet de jouer avec ses
pièces donc pour quelqu'un qui qui
débute c'est toujours intéressant ça
donnera des parties très animé le
deuxième grand coup que peuvent avoir
les noirs cette position il s'est donc
c'est sortir le cavalier fils oui pour
contre attaquer directement le pion donc
cavalier f6 c'est une variante
secondaire je dirais je pense que dame
prend dessins quelques principes al mais
j'ai quand même étudié cavaliers
attisant que je pense qu'on va commencer
par l'étude direct de cavaliers apsys
avant de passer que possible au plat
principal
donc là il pas d'accord non qu'on va
voir dans la suite le coup qu'a réussi
donc qui paraît un bout intéressant
puisque on développe la pièce et en même
temps on fait tout de suite pression sur
le pion central mais on préfère le
prendre avec une cavaliers évitant ainsi
de mettre la dame en danger d'attac donc
là cavalier sera moins sensible aux
attaques puisque s'il est attaqué par un
cavalier mais il peut au moins c'est
changer il n'y a pas de perte de temps
donc
donc voilà le poulpe principal alors que
peuvent faire les blancs face à
qualifier alors sa cavalière 6 donc la
grande question donc
la question principale dans cette
position géré ses fans c'est le coup ces
deux c4
c'est le coup ces deux c4 qui est quand
même une question intéressante puisque
le pion défend le plan des 5 et l'a donc
ce qui est important à savoir c'est
qu'avec les noirs dans cette position on
a la possibilité de sacrifier un pion
des débuts déjà dès le deuxième coup
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
d'assez peu commun par le coup c7 c6
voilà on pousse ses pions
donc là on attaque à nouveau le plan des
le plan c 6 veut récupérer donc le plein
d'essence et ya pas moins une défense
est la seule solution pour défendre
finalement ces deux c'est de continuer
de prendre d'accepter le sacrifice de
pions mais cette position est très tout
à fait choix pour les deux semaines du
très long alors effectivement
intéressant puisque un contrôle très
fort des noirs sur le centre on va déjà
sept cas tissier défendu par l'adami
travail et donc peu coût des quatre
était possible et très certainement même
si c'est sûr mais mon prochain où les
noirs ont joué cinq ils vont ils vont
complètement de look et ceux qui ont
acquis ce pion des deux restaurants un
très fort contrôle sur le cas des caps
oui tout à fait donc adore ces cas là
donc c'est vrai que le pion va venir sur
la case 5 donc j'ai enlevé les flèches
et donc le cavalier va contre les gaz de
5 ce pion va venir là et le fou va
s'installer donc sur la case saissac
également donc le fauve à venir sur la
case c5 et le contrôle du centre sera
énorme les noirs vont pouvoir très
facilement rock et le plus vite possible
et avoir des compensations pour le pion
donc c'est ça peut s'envisager c'est
quand même assez intéressant à ses
actifs on va maintenant donc revenir à
ce qui peut être conseillé pour les
blancs sur cavaliers m6 le coût plus
raisonnable
évitez de rentrer donc dans les
complications du sacrifice c'est tout
simplement jouer au centre donc
installer un pion au centre voilà on
recherche le plus il faut pas chercher à
reprendre ce pion mais plutôt essayer de
gagner du temps de développement
exactement donc on garde en gagne du
temps de développement et après
cavaliers prend pions on se devait
hop on fait ce qu'on dira on suit les
principes fondamentaux du jeu d'échecs
on a inclus au centre donc c'est quand
même plutôt agréable et après j'ai six
dans sa position se développe tout
tranquillement fou de deux fous j'ai
cette c4 maintenant n'hésitons pas à
chasser le cavalier donc le pion c4 qui
attaquent le cavalier en dessin alors
toujours le duo pions standard un peu
aux signes dans le contrôle du centre
comme sade le pion c4 et pion des cas
très fort qui contrôle mais beaucoup de
quatre centrales à gaz des cinq classes
de 5 qui est qui font qu'ils sont une
belle avancée et souvent on conseille
souvent enfin évidemment ce n'est pas
une généralité absolue mais souvent de
d'abord de jouer le pion pour ensuite
sortir le cavalier puisque après on
pourra mettre une tour derrière aussi
parfois de certaines positions
donc il faut se demander un maximum
d'espacé voilà tout à fait et après ces
quatre donc cavalier p 6 le cavalier
doit revenir on se développe
l'adversaire se développe aussi
maintenant on fait le fameux coup de
cavaliers que tu avais conseillé d'en
cavaliers c3 est bon je pense que cette
position est
donne un avantage aux blancs un petit
avantage d'ouverture qui est quand même
assez agréable il ya d'autres analyses
on pourrait continuer un petit peu plus
loin mais je crois que là pour l'instant
ce qui est important savoir quand même
c'est qu'après par un plat coup comme
cabanis et six dans cette position qui
est une attaque directe du pion central
oui avec dan avec le cavalier fouet la
dame donc trois pièces qui attaque et le
pion central et va dans ces cas là il
faut le pousser au bout c'est le pion et
et continuez donc à jouer avec cette
avance de développement et ce duo
central donc une position plutôt
favorable donc à bali et 6 une variante
donc on va revenir dans calais beaucoup
cavalière six cavaliers m6 une vente
intéressante mais je crois quand même
que le coût principal c'est quand même
bien d'un 30 et 5 dans cette position
oui d'accord dame prend des sags
on n'a pas peur finalement deux
cavaliers c3 le coup qui suit puisque la
dame peut bouger la desserte attaquer
mais dans cette position elle a donc
deux choix principaux elle assoit la
casa sac et la case des si ce monsieur
mais dans les deux cas de figure donc
les noirs obtiennent un jeu assez actif
7 qui a ses actifs puisqu'on voit quand
même que le fou va pouvoir se développer
ici ou là éventuellement le cavalier
peut vite se développer et toutes les
pièces vont sortir rapidement donc c'est
une ouverture qui quand même a été jouée
par de très fort joueur et c'est la
seule ouverture où on sort s'adapte
comme ça dangereusement son sens que ce
soit dangereux district sommes d'accord
en faire quand même petit en quittant le
développement c'est un anti temps de
développement un petit en développement
d'un côté la fatigue en cette dame va
trouver des cas surtout la casa 5 qui
l'a complètement cette case complètement
à gauche
oui la casa
qu'on peut montrer ici cette case là qui
est une case safe
on va dire pour la dague parce qu'elle
n'est pas facilement un tacle à part les
blancs on ne voit pas trop comment après
continuer la pourchasse oui là pour
chasser la dame s'est passablement une
grosse erreur qu'on voit parfois on
partie débutants évidemment ça serait le
coup dams et 6
donc il faut éviter absolument puisqu'il
est contré tout simplement par un
clouage énorme puisque voilà après
foulée cinq cyclos âge
le roi est derrière la dame peut plus
bouger le câble du fou ici est protégé
par le clavier et c'est une paire de
dames tout de suite d'où le danger comme
ça de son tir saddam tout de suite pensé
un piège de débutants sapiens le
débutant que c'est quand même important
de le signaler
bon une autre erreur qui est moins grave
mais on veut dire qu un coût qui n'est
pas extraordinaire dans cette position
c'est le ku'damm de 8 le coût des huit
c'est vrai que là on les planches au t4
et
donne des huit sait pas on peut pas
considérer ce coup comme un coup très
ambitieux on a l'impression que les
noirs n'ont pas bougé alors on va voir
quelle brendan décide alors de demander
si on va commencer par d'anne decis on
va commencer encore par la variante
secondaire avant de passer au plat
principal donc d'un des six les bleus
encore une fois joue au centre donc les
noirs se développe la province en tout
et classique cavaliers f3 les blancs
continuent à développer et la a6 alors à
6 c'est un coût qui est assez
caractéristique au coude mt 6 donc c'est
pas un goût qui est très facile à
comprendre
la première a priori mais souvent dans
cette position les noirs ème place et
leurs cavaliers sur la case c6 voilà
donc pour mettre leurs fous sur la case
g4 et tous et le cavalier et et plus
tard placé le roi donc faire le bon
d'accord pourquoi se poursuit donc
locaux à 6 en général est destiné à
éviter les attaques du cavalier sur la
case pessac voilà qui parfois peuvent
être peuvent être très dangereuses on
peut très bien imaginer imaginons tout
de suite que si les noirs est vite joué
palois si si j'vous directement qu'avait
laissé 6 peut-être que tout simplement
cavaliers b5 par exemple d'homme on va
dire 17 oui et peut-être tout simplement
il faut être quatre et on voit plus haut
comment ça va être difficile à défendre
il faudra jouer ce coup là il a pris de
fous j'ai trois ans menace c4 après sa
difficile en grèce est clair que déjà
on attaque directement le pion aux
menaces surtout donc cavalier français 7
avec une fourchette
roy tour puisque le fou défend donc donc
c'est dangereux dans ce beau c'est
dangereux donc assis une bonne idée à 6
et là maintenant donc g3 un coup
intéressant pour éventuellement placer
le fou sur la case z4 est attaqué la
dame en d6 évidemment quand on joue g36
toujours peut placer le flou ambiant
kétou et pour placer évidemment le
fameux fou donc sur le flanc ghetto
c'est d'ailleurs le fou sur la cage et
le voilà tout ça si on partait de
l'autre côté on aurait affaibli nous
place blanche pour rien exactement
donc j'ai droit fou g4 on se développe
ensuite et en cloud on peut la pièce une
petite attaque du fou a donc dans cette
position le fou vient sur la case h5
il faut juste savoir que si le fou prend
le cavalier sur la kf3 la dame reprend
et attaque bessette et voilà c'est à
dire que si les noirs prennent le pion
la dame en f3 se jette sur le plan des
sept essais la tour qui est perdu et
après ça va être la tour qui va être
perdu donc c'est un premier piège donc
dans cette position après h3 le fou
revient sur la case h5 est là donc on
joue fou j'ai de lons développe
tranquillement cavani c6 le
développement que j'avais signalé tout à
l'heure alors là oui on se développe sur
roc camp rock et on termine son
développement par fouet trois avec une
position compliquée mais tout à fait
choix pour les blancs entre car en plus
du son qui sera très tendue puisque
c'est une partie à recomposer on voit
que le roi blanc est allé le roi et le
roi noir à la dame
donc ça sera une partie tendue d'amd 6e
c'est un coup à ces nouveaux qui
qui fait un peu pour les gens qui aiment
avoir des sensations fortes à une somme
que veut dire deux jours français qui
jouait pas mal ça je sais pas si c'est
pas de prix je crois que c'est cyril
marcerou soit introduit se confrontent
donc voilà donc on va revenir à la
grande variante maintenant ce qui est
donc qu'ils aient d'am-dam à 5 donc sur
damas ac beaucoup naturel à jouer c'est
et 4 donc on s'installe au centre
cavaliers f6 fou c4 donc là on se
développe normalement on fait pression
tout de suite sur le pion sur le pur ou
7 ça peut toujours servir un peu montré
cette belle diagonale
jean-luc ici tout à fait fou ces 4 et 6
un petit coup développement qui est
utile parce que c'est vrai que la dame
en 1-5 quelquefois donc risques menacent
d'être attaqué par un coup comme fou des
deux donc on voit que le fouet et en
face de la dame dans cette position et
donc ses six c'est un coût qui permet à
la dame de bouger on valoir de starz de
s'échapper et lui donne plus de cases
pour pour pour se déplacer c'est
rajoutent 7 des diagonales donc ces six
cavaliers f3 fou et sac un coup
classique bon actuellement on joue
également le coup j'ai quatre pour
prouver le cavalier donc sur flu g4 en
chasse le fou faut pas avoir peur
si on donne le four f3 comme ça on donne
la paire de fou donc là les blancs se
retrouve avec le phocéen et le fou c4 il
atteint interview est toujours un petit
avantage mais après pour vous la finale
tout à fait après frêche ça qu on
continue à chasser le fou par g4 le four
revient sur g6 on nous fout les deux
avec le fameux vis-à-vis donc entre le
fouet la dame qui permet éventuellement
de placer ce cavalier la soie case c3 de
le placer quelques fois de faire des
combinaisons en mettant sur la case des
cinq pour attaquer la dame
voilà tendre des pièges alors d'ailleurs
on va peut-être venir juste un peu en
arrière
l'udc oui sur un piège peut-être plus
justement classique si les noirs ne joue
pas ce couscous et 6 ici dans cette
position imaginons par exemple que les
noirs jouent un coût faible plus fait
beaucoup plus faible qu'on me 6 par
exemple qui enferme le font donc les
parcs et peint beaucoup développement il
ya un piège classique évidemment joue
fou des deux est par exemple sur un coût
faible comme kung fu des six qui alors
le développer une pièce de préparer le
bac
eh bien il ya un gros piège n'ont
peut-être pas fou des six pardon tout au
fond le set justement en flèche de fous
des deux voilà et la fossette
imaginons donc tout de suite et bien il
ya un piège avec cavaliers des cinq
longs relais dames est attaqué par le
fou on peut vérifier qu'elle est pas
possible de venir ici puisque le gall
cavaliers elle peut pas venir ici
puisqu'elle fou ici donc c'est la même
chose et donc il reste qu'une case cette
pauvre dame qui est attaqué c'est de
venir sur la case à 4 et dans ce cas là
le piège concis tout simplement jouer au
foot et cinq échecs petite combinaison
piège un peu un peu classique je permets
de la donner parce que j'ai souvent
l'occasion de la placer dans des beats
etc
et si la dame est obligé de prendre le
fou fou les cinq qui attaque qui fait
chaque attaque leroy et adamo là et donc
la dame qui est donc obligé de prendre
le fou et là on peut jouer dans
cavaliers français c'est très bon
confort gilbert a lâché 3 voilà donc une
petite combinaison bien utile qui
explique notamment pourquoi il faut
jouer ces 6 pourquoi c'est souvent
prioritaires voilà donc une petite
combine qui peut qui peut être placé un
temps d'autant vraiment ça c'est clair
c'est un piège qui est toujours utiles à
connaître
voilà alors de revenir à notre donc on
renie rien à ces six boxes et si on se
développe par cavalier f3 là le goût
principal donc
c'est fou f5 bien phu g4 le tout à
l'heure j'ai analysé donc floue g4 qui
ne marchaient pas donc moi qui marche
mais qui permet donc aux blancs d'avoir
une position correcte là après dames
deux dames de très important donc ce
déplacement avec le fou mans d2 et la
dame en deux est très important
puisqu'il permet au roi dont vous avez
vous envisagé le grand roque voilà et
donc d'avoir la tacc face au roi adverse
qui soit restent au centre soit va du
petit côté il y en a pas peur de perdre
le pion à ses deux jambes on attend ce
genre de position on n'a jamais perdre
peur de perdre du plan c'est donc le fou
g6 qui attaquent le pion ces deux mais
nous le verrons plus tard le pion ces
deux souvent n'est pas dangereux à
perdre puisque les noirs perdrait
beaucoup de temps d'accord on va aller
manger après on verra ça alors donc fou
et 5
on continue par food et de le
développement que j'ai précisé ça c'est
classique en les invitant à 5 c'est
vraiment le petit coup de fouet des deux
qui est viré c'est la clé quand même de
la position blanche pour la scandinave
continuer exactement continuer à gagner
du temps au niveau du développement
toujours le problème de cette dame on a
trouvé finalement avec un développement
simple des moyens de encore gagner du
temps sur la dame adverse
voilà est donc là le couple est encore
une fois comme tu dis c'est le coup
cavaliers des cinq donc qui découvrent
la tacc du full sur la dame
la dame doit revenir sur la caisse des 8
on prend en rêve si ce là deux coups
principaux dans cette position soit on
prend de l'adamant f6 auquel cas les
blancs encore une fois sacrifié le pion
ces deux c'est à dire qu'il continue à
développer leurs pièces pour faire le
grand roque part d'un e 2 suivi de grand
roque amena camp et donc après dames 2
si on prend le
le fameux pioncer 2 on s'expose tout
simplement à un avantage de
développement puisque là on voit que le
fossé de n'est pas très bien développé
mais par contre on a développé trois
quatre pièces on a le roi à l'abri et on
avait un sénateur qui sont prêtes à
jouer et prénom c'est une grosse attaque
autant dire que ceux qui ont ces deux
n'est pas prenable alors ce qui veut
dire qu'après dames 2 donc là il ya pas
mal de coups théorique
assez assez complexe il ya des petits
pièges marrant par exemple après le coup
fou des six qui à coup développement
tout à fait honnête oui là qu'est ce
qu'on fait ses fans eh bien je sais pas
tout de suite moi je pense depuis tout à
l'heure qu'on peut jouer je vois pas
trop ce que tu veux dire là tout de
suite mais je fous g5 paraît toujours
tentant un peu tôt c'est fou j'ai cinq
mais on va on va d'abord se développer
on va d'abord on va d'abord se sortir
les pièces pour attaquer d'accord et sur
bessac donc là il ya un piège mais un
piège noir c'est que les noirs dans
cette position propose une combinaison
mais ça ne marche pas proposa
combinaison fou prend des 5
wibox est une combinaison amusante
puisque après prise on prend de la dame
chèque et là on peut se dire qu'après un
coup comme cavalier 17 la dame va venir
sur la case c6 on vient de sacrifier une
pièce où est donc là je vais revenir
juste à la position le fou donc vient de
se sacrifier contre les lions le plomber
sa capture c'est si simple mais après
donc dame c6 donc dans cette position
après le ku'damm c6 wii qui attaquent la
tour et le fou est un honneur de gagner
une pièce oui on a l'air de gagner une
pièce qu'est ce qui se passe et
d'intervention il ya un coup incroyable
c'est qu'on joue au 3e set avala qui
défendent tous en protège tout mais là
tu vas me dire jean luc qu'est ce qui se
passe après le coucher cinq puisque fuku
g5
ghana dame dans cette position et je te
le fais pas dire qu'est-ce qui se passe
j'ai 5 et bien on donne la dengue
contrefout d'un peu incroyable en a
donné donc une dame
et là on se retrouve donc avec si on
compte le matériel avec deux pièces pour
une pour une dame à aigle et noir mais
on a un coup incroyable c'est tour ses
huit pour est d'accord qui finalement
est très très dangereux puisque la tour
attaque la dame et les pions ces deux
juges observé d'accord donc il ya un
dégagement total sur la colonne c est un
bon on imagine après tour c'est à coup
comme damas six oui même si damas quatre
qui protège dame à 84 ans va jouer au
meilleur coût directement le cavalier
attaque la dame encore n'a pas encore la
dame doit de protéger le plan c'est de
toute façon l'important bien sûr et là
on peut tout simplement prendre un sur
échec est d'accord si le roi bouge il ya
ce qu'on appelle un échec à la
découverte la tombe bien ces trois
attaques leroy et après il y aura prises
et après on va manger la dame d'accord
donc
donc c'est un joli variantes qui permet
de notre école que les noirs ont quand
même du jeu et si on prend la tour
puisqu'on a comme on à bercy on prend la
tour on va tous être des leurs en
arrière tout simplement
à prendre avec le fou et après on
apprend donc on va peut-être d'abord
avant de faire pour ces deux on va faire
un échec qui tu es chez toi glisser un
échec en arabe le roi bouge et
maintenant on va on va faire ça pourtant
c'est de vous [ __ ] en couches ou
presque français de nouveau prise et
cavaliers et en local et en l'air et
après d'apprendre on comprend avec la
tour le roi prend hillary en tant que
cavalier on prend le cas et on a deux
pièces pour une tour on a deux pièces
pour une tour donc on est mieux avec les
noix ou mieux de démence
donc on fait maintenant revenir en
arrière c'est un peu compliqué mais il
faut il faut le voir leur compris ça
donc ça c'est une vente compliqué c'est
pas la vente la plus importante ce qui
nous intéresse le plus maintenant ça va
être deux c'était juste de savoir qu'il
fallait faire grand roque et attaquer
avec les blancs d'accord donc dans cette
position le courant rock ça c'est la
position qui nous intéresse d'accord
maintenant nous allons nous intéresser à
la dernière variante autant que de cette
partie scandinave
cg pro f 6 donc on double un pion en
général c'est douteux mais là dans cette
position c'est le cas sur huit ça reste
assez solide fougue et trois pour la
cette fois par contre on peut prendre on
peut toujours sacrifié le pion par dame
2 oui nous mais c'est un peu moins clair
c'est un peu moins clair c'est un peu
moins ça peut jouer mais c'est un peu
moins clair sinon le couffo b3 pour
préparer des mets deux d'accord en
cavalier 17,1 me deux dames c7 est donc
d'amener cet l'été dams et 7 comme on va
le voir bientôt c'est qu'après cavagna
jcat qui chasse le fou le four revient
on fait grand roque
mais là les noirs qui n'ont pas envie de
subir d'attac
ils vont faire grandes rock également
d'accord et une position très solide
même si à un pion doublé oui voilà donc
je pense que là on a montré suffisamment
de choses pour pouvoir sortir ces pièces
et on voit que finalement avoir sorti la
dame
c'était pas si mal si elle a fait une
petite balade alors que ce type de
position je lui ressemble un petit peu
à la différence près des pions doublé à
la défense
tarkan oui tout à fait 20 ou là où le
schéma les schémas de pièces sont
sensiblement les mêmes
on peut considérer que la scandinave est
la petite soeur de la défense scandinave
c'est dans la même famille de la rocade
de la carreau car voilà on a fait tout
en effet le tour donc on a vu des
grandes variantes rendement intéressant
donc il faut les creuser évidemment
parce qu'on a donné les grandes lignes
on peut pas tout expliquer aux échecs
même sur une variante c'est bien
tellement de choses que je pense qu'on a
donnés régulièrement les grandes
indications sur cette défense qui est
vraiment intéressante
je crois qu'il faut absolument la
connaître quand on veut 4 parce que si
on est face à un spécialiste de la
scandinave
si l'on va on va avoir de grosses
difficultés et et avec les noix pourquoi
pas l'inscrire à son répertoire
c'est une ouverture qui est un peu moins
joué que les autres comme la sicilienne
par une équipe qui évite quand même
qu'ils évitent les complications
finalement je dire que ça évite les
milieux de jeu très compliqué on joue
avec des pièces c'est quand même c'est
intéressant pour les joueurs
intéressants pour les joueurs
tranquilles eux qui veulent pas rentrer
dans une cohabitation trop compliqué pas
trop travail a d'ailleurs voilà c'est ça
l'important
donc c'est vraiment une arme qu'on peut
conseiller à celui qui avait envie
d'avoir un jeu plus calmes et est pas
pas avoir d ouverture trop techniques à
apprendre à parler petit piège qu'on a
donné donc il faut connaître on sait pas
une ouverture qui demande de grandes de
grandes connaissances théoriques
on n'a pas du tout on peut on peut jouer
sans trop de problème voilà il est je
crois qu'on a fini sur 7 sur cette
défense candidats on a fait un peu le
tour
eh bien merci de nous avoir suivi on
espère que vous allez devenir un expert
sur ces la défense des hommes du nord
voilà au revoir